yeah pinging hello welcome to this video
and then I shall ask the lights like
it's my opponent and I'm going with if I
that's Martin songs under pretty strong
international master i think is close to
2500 nowadays so will i play my I guess
I check my somewhat rusty Bishop before
lines that need some overhaul but yeah
we'll see what he's up to yeah this is
one of the better lines against it there
is g6 yeah and I never quite know what I
should go g6 or take now why this inning
for some c4 base setup which is a pretty
good bind so something like this and
creature before sometimes an option but
okay quit before it doesn't make all
that much sense iam yeah maybe kounya 7
wasn't the best idea ever it runs into
95 I mean I defy this probably not
extremely dangerous in this particular
situation but in general I wonder if
this is an idea 10 a queen before I
would like to trade Quincy and this
pollution knight on c6 is really not
great but what do I do with it
not that the f6 analysis is brilliant
and yeah i was thinking Queenie five but
yeah i'm not sure what they do after 95
but castles twin d was my idea maybe he
just goes queen quincy one man but ok i
mean it still feels a little bit awkward
for white quincy one could be an issue
but my queen will go to c5 that that's
not such a bad square by quincy one
Bishop e6 rook t125 could be could be
could be okay yeah this line is not my
my cup of tea with this with this 95c
voice i think a little bit of an
annoyance for black I don't really see a
good solution to this so this is one of
the one of the issues with this a night
before check line
[Music]
night will come to the five that's what
it is or should be five yeah okay before
I am not so sure that this is so much of
an issue i want to i get out of the
checks so 95 is not attacking this with
tempo before I don't know this is not
that big a deal
it also weakens his position a little
bit okay and is he threatening something
f or maybe f4 here could be a threat
it's 94 movie onite deform threatening
to tell you too well that's actually
complicated
I can actually do this right like
politics 94 that isn't so bad it doesn't
have great squares for the Queen I'm
always forking on I have tricks hmm okay
what did I overlooked did that will look
something I thought that this is good I
mean couldn't be two nite xf3 or queen
c3 is blundering the bishop so queen dee
29 p 3 i'm attacking this okay he can
move the bishop of course that that's
possible but yeah I thought I always
have c5 as a as a decent option at least
this let's do it maybe maybe I'm
weakening my position too much but c4 is
a week square it moves the Bishop Knight
g4 could be could be on wow could be but
I'm reasonably active and there are
still tricks am Queen B 2 and so on
that's always night xf3 okay this I have
to do I have no other square I mean or
other staff knows where to put it okay
so if I grab it this F for coming but
okay that's probably not the end of the
world
I wonder if f5 is now a threat that's a
bit dicey I Scott f1 self
hyh three if i can get it in would be
nice so I don't know if I this any good
but I'm going to play it so what's going
on here I he just plays for the a porn
huh and estimated that really did time
morning and I let that I underestimated
quite considerably
now that was bad I should have thought
about this more thoroughly neither three
years at shaky even on c3 shoot now that
was bad I don't think that this was this
was terrible with the knight on d4 I
just I just completely completely did
not understand that is so quickly with
the pawn
yeah always feel like I'm giving away
stuff for no reason like this one okay
now gee Quinn g5 everything wins the
check there is stupid check queen g5
actually wasn't all that good but it
isn't sure it's enough he's still
promoting black resigned ah stupid
really stupid stuff I don't I get in to
examine mode now that's very strange Wow
why did was what's that very strange so
let's let's see it felt like I did a
decent job there with putting their
getting the night there and everything
but maybe I'm just completely wrong be
sure seven okay that let us strong I'm
very interested about this I cannot
believe that I will rest in this
position that's it's actually that's
where it would be very strange but I
definitely miss played it that much is
clear look a four Wow yes that's a good
move you cannot really attack it with
the bishop hi I am that's good he cannot
attack it why I be three RC six and I
actually can can double it i want it
makes an awful lot of sense now yet a
for me and then I just did not did not
realize this
I am I'm definitely in some trouble this
is this is probably by far far too slow
yeah he it's already too late now that
was a really big mistake that I didn't
understand this correctly the position
the voice is better for wide support
it's got more space either I just like
this i really dislike this position and
I don't know how really to improve their
for black here you kind of you're
sitting in this maroc see by it it's not
it's really not fun I think actually
that this made some sense what I did but
it's still not a good position i get f
foil to immediately win the Queen check
no wow yeah so okay very well deserved
victory for white in any case ok guys
thanks for watching